revisemos un poco lo que hicimos en el
vídeo anterior donde tenemos este tubo
con forma extraña donde en el lado
izquierdo tenemos un líquido que entra a
una velocidad de 1 con una presión de
izquierda derecha de 1 y el área donde
está la entrada es a 1 y a la salida
tenemos las mismas variables pero con un
2 en lugar de 1 no usamos esta
información para encontrar esta ecuación
de aquí voy a bajar un poco para que le
veamos la ecuación
tenemos que el trabajo de entrada al
sistema va a ser igual a la presión de
entrada multiplicada por la masa del
volumen que entra en un período de
tiempo dividido entre la densidad del
líquido que tenemos la energía potencial
simplemente es la masa por la gravedad
por la altura lo podemos ver como la
cantidad de energía que se encuentra
aquí en este periodo de tiempo y la
energía cinética durante ese periodo
será la masa del volumen del fluido
multiplicado por su velocidad al
cuadrado dividido entre 2 y por supuesto
todo eso tiene que ser igual a la
energía de salida así que esto es el
trabajo de salida la presión dos por la
masa entre la densidad esto es el
trabajo de salida trabajo
de salida especialmente cuánto trabajo
puede realizar esta columna de líquido
de este lado y será un volumen de
líquido equivalente al de la entrada en
un período de tiempo t cualquiera que
sea este volumen de entrada en el mismo
periodo de tiempo tendremos el mismo
volumen de salida aunque quizás aquí
afuera podríamos tener un cilindro un
poco más largo porque el área de salida
es más pequeña más o menos así
así que del lado derecho tendremos un
cilindro más largo y más angosto pero
que tendrá el mismo volumen que el
líquido de entrada por eso decimos que
el trabajo que está columna puede hacer
en la misma cantidad de tiempo será la
presión de salida multiplicada por la
masa de esta columna dividida entre la
densidad del líquido y tenemos en cuenta
que la densidad va a ser la misma en
todo el sistema más la masa de esta
columna más la masa de esta columna que
es la misma masa que a la entrada aunque
ahora esta masa va a tener más energía
potencial ya que este cilindro se
encuentra más alto a una altura h 2
más la energía cinética que es la masa
de este cilindro de líquido por su
velocidad al cuadrado dividido entre 2
esto es la energía potencial de salida y
esto es la energía cinética de salida
esto de aquí es la ecuación de berlín
pero podemos simplificarlo bastante más
vemos que hay término m de masa en cada
uno de los elementos de esta ecuación
por lo que podemos eliminarlo de todos
ellos o dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre m y como no me gusta esta
densidad en el denominador vamos a
multiplicar ambos lados de la ecuación
por la densidad y nos queda voy a hacer
espacio para poder escribir
la ecuación
en un color vibrante
nos va a quedar la presión 1
más
la densidad por la gravedad por la
altura 1
más la densidad por la velocidad de
entrada a velocidad 1 al cuadrado entre
2 y esto es igual a la presión de salida
a la presión 2 más la densidad por la
gravedad por la altura pero en este caso
es la altura 2 la de salida más la
densidad por la velocidad de salida 2 al
cuadrado entre 2
esta es la ecuación de berlín y tiene
mucha información por ejemplo nos dice
asumiendo que las alturas son constantes
por lo que podemos olvidarnos de estos
términos
si la altura es constante si tengo una
velocidad más alta y todo este término
de la izquierda es constante
este término de la izquierda es
constante entonces mis expresiones van a
ser más bajas
pensemos en ello si la altura es
constante ese término del medio no va a
cambiar este de acá
pero si esto se incrementa la velocidad
va a incrementarse
pero todo es constante la presión va a
tener que disminuir de manera similar si
la presión aumenta entonces la velocidad
se va a decrementar quizás son un poco
raro
esto es lo que hace que los aviones
puedan volar y otras cosas geniales que
veremos más adelante pero ahora veamos
si podemos usar esta ecuación de
bernouilli para algo útil y les
recomiendo que la memoricen pues no es
difícil de recordar
tenemos la presión
más la energía potencial en dónde
tenemos la densidad del lugar de la masa
más la energía cinética en donde tenemos
la densidad en lugar de la masa
y ya ha dicho esto vamos a aplicar esta
ecuación para resolver un problema
y vamos a conservar la fórmula y borrar
todos los demás vamos a hacer espacio de
manera que voy a quedarme aquí con la
fórmula
y voy a poder definir aquí un problema
voy a dibujar aquí
una taza
- así
que tiene una tapa
y tienes cierto fluido en ella más o
menos así y digamos que aquí hay vacío
no hay aire aquí hay vacío
digamos que ah
h metros o cualquier unidad de distancia
abajo de la superficie voy a perforar un
hueco
un pequeño agujero y aquí es fluido va a
comenzar a salir este líquido va a
comenzar a salir por este agujero mi
pregunta para ustedes es cuál será esta
velocidad de salida que le voy a poner
2 de este fluido como función de la
altura h un dato más que les doy sobre
este agujero es que es muy pequeño tanto
que el área de este agujero que voy a
llamarle a 2 q respecto al área del
líquido que se encuentra aquí en esta
superficie el área de la boca de esta
tasa que voy a llamar a 1 es que el área
del agujero área 2 es igual a un
milésimo una milésima parte del área de
la superficie de la tasa es un hueco muy
pequeño en comparación con el área de la
boca de la tasa con todos estos datos
vemos si podemos encontrar esta
velocidad de salida del líquido veamos
los elementos de esta ecuación de
bernouilli
cuál será la presión de entrada la
presión en la superficie del líquido que
está al vacío eso tendrá una presión de
entrada igual a cero por lo que mi
presión de entrada vamos a escribirlo
acá mi presión de entrada
va a ser igual a 0
cuál es la altura de la entrada
vamos a asumir que este hueco
fue hecho a h igual a 0 por lo que la
altura de la entrada aquí está
h uno va a ser igual
y cuál será la velocidad de entrada
sabemos que a partir de la ecuación de
continuidad
que la velocidad de entrada multiplicada
por el área de entrada en este caso
nuestra velocidad de entrada
multiplicada por el área de entrada va a
ser igual a la velocidad de salida por
el área de salida así que será igual a
la velocidad de salida 2 por el área de
salida 2 y también sabemos que el área
de salida es una milésima del área de
entrada así que nos va a quedar de uno
por uno
es igual a
de dos por a uno entre mil
simplificando nos queda que la velocidad
inicial va a ser igual a la velocidad de
salida entre 1000
y esto es bueno saberlo y ahora ya
tenemos los tres elementos del lado
izquierdo de esta ecuación
y que tenemos en el lado derecho que va
a ser presión 2
la presión 2
está en este otro punto presión 2 y me
acabo de dar cuenta que me estoy
quedando sin tiempo así que nos veremos
en el siguiente vídeo